can I have a quote here from the late
author Philip Roth and quote is the road
to hell is paved with works in progress
yeah that's worse than good intentions
right and it's not a question like it's
a statement and a question I guess in
that do you have any ideas on that I
know it's it's kind of a thing I'm just
throwing out here but well I think
unfinished works are that the kind of
characteristic debris of the writers
life of any visionaries life I mean that
the discards that Leonardo da Vinci had
in his studio were prodigious and you
you just have a lot of ideas and you
can't do them all and one of the methods
that I've developed over the years is to
actually set aside a new idea and give
it a two-week rest and and check in with
it in two weeks to see whether you even
remember the idea and and the key to
doing that as a writer is not to write
it down see it's like a basic rule that
I have is that if you have an idea and
as a writer your immediate goal is to
write it down get it down because that's
what writers do if you can train your
brain not to do that you're gonna have
much better product in the long run
because you're not writing every single
thing down including every bad thing so
by not writing it down when you revisit
it two weeks from now if you don't
remember it that's great that means one
lousy idea went away as opposed to
trying to do something with every single
idea that you have and so I think that's
part of what creative people learn is
how to manage their own minds and
because I was an accountant son I
long-ago analyze the creative process
the creative mind and decided that they
weren't just crazy the way a lot of
people think they actually is a method
to creativity and in fact it spreads
across every discipline whether you're a
physicist or a mathematician or you know
an inventor or a writer or an artist
the
creative process has the same steps in
the same general pattern so if you can
understand the process then you aren't
nearly as neurotic as you are if you
don't understand it you know one of my
goals was to not be crazy
Salvador Salvador Dali said one of my
favorite things about this he said the
difference between myself and a madman
is that I am not mad
and I love that because it's it's
exactly what I'm talking about it's it's
understanding the method in your madness
as Shakespeare put it and if you can
understand that then you don't have to
be unhappy and neurotic in order to be a
productive writer
speaking of which writing things down do
you make lists I do make lists but kind
of limited I mean what I what I have
instead is a very complicated method of
time management that involves a chart
that I make regularly and the chart has
room for some lists but most of what I
do is doing the same things in
compartments of time that I believe are
the right compartments for what I do I
know in our last interview which was
about a year a year and a half ago we
talked about one of your books and you
talked about time management and that
you know creative people that get things
done they're very aware of time so then
I started to monitor myself am I really
as aware of time as I should be do it
maybe I'm not a where I where enough and
so it became this new thing where you
were talking about before that just that
most people that are very productive
they know exactly how much time
something takes them and and I thought
that was interesting because I thought I
was aware of time and then when I
started listening to that I realized now
I'm actually not because I don't know
how much time and I'm you know and it
ends up where I'm not giving myself
enough of it so it can't consume me too
aware of time though where it becomes a
hindrance yeah I think that's possible
in today's world especially with all the
Apple watches and technology devices for
keeping track of time
and that's a whole separate subject but
it's very connected with creativity
because time is all we have I mean there
there are two things in life you can
manage one is work and one is time and
work one of them is infinite and the
other one is finite so without even
talking further about it you think about
that and realise that by definition you
cannot manage an infinite thing right
then infinite element can't be managed
but a finite one can but for some reason
along the way as we grow up in in the
world we think that the wrong one is
infinite and we think it's time and it's
not true the only one that time is
infinite for is God for the rest of us
it's all too finite but what is infinite
is work work is completely infinite
because good work produces more work you
know as my son once told me dad you'll
never catch up I was telling Emily oh I
really hope I can catch up this weekend
and he goes you you're gonna never catch
up and I he's right because work is
infinite if it's good work it generates
more work if it's bad work it generates
more work so no matter how you look at
it work is infinite you can't manage
work you can only manage time and you
can manage time if you know how to
compartmentalize it in a productive way
that works with your particular mind
what I mean by that is that I think that
the first step in manage managing time
other than keeping track of your time
like you were talking about I when I
gave classes on that and when I'm
consulting with individuals about their
time management I always started by
having them make a weekly chart of their
time you ask people how many hours are
there in a week and they don't even know
because they just never occurred to them
but there is a finite number of hours
and every week and what I want to know
first is what do you do with those hours
exactly how many hours do you spend
sleeping eating you know walking
exercising talking on the phone texting
emailing and and working on the things
you're supposed to work on and doing
errands and doing all the other things
that you don't really want to do but you
kind of have to do to be human so once
you know that the next step is to figure
out attention span because when I was a
professor I say of students who would
come and say they were failing history
and they didn't get it because they're
spending six hours a day studying
history and I go wait a minute six hours
a day yeah because I'm failing in it I
go well it's very possible that you're
spending too much time not too little
time because what happens during those
six hours is probably not the most
productive way of studying history and
we would rearrange their pattern so that
they would actually study history only
one hour a day but do it in
uninterrupted a way and and here's what
you do during that hour etc and so what
we're trying to figure out is what is
your attention span for an individual
subject so if we know that this person
can pay attention to history for one
hour and after that you know her mind
starts wandering then it's complete
waste of time
literally to spend more than one hour
studying history at a time that's what I
call a compartment of time so if it
comes to your writing how much time can
you write being fully focused and not
thinking about the outside world etc and
that's the compartment that where your
attention span is at its max because if
you're doing anything where your
attention span is not at its max you are
basically wasting your time and your
energy and those both of those things
have a negative kind of depressive
effect on your motivation they're not
good so you really want to figure out
your attention span and then you want to
arrange your life in compartments of
time
that have to do with attention span and
when it comes to being conscious of time
one of my rules has been from the very
first time I started thinking of these
things when I was like 19 so I stopped
wearing a watch because I realized that
the only way I was going to be
productive with my kind of interests and
activities was if I lived in my own time
and did not live in everybody else's
time but everywhere you look there's a
clock on the wall there's a big bin on
the horizon there's you know television
monitors with countdowns on them there's
everything out there reminding you of
the world's time and the world's time is
not your time you don't have all the
time in the world you have your own time
so I discovered a method years ago which
is simply the stopwatch method which is
that instead of using clocks use a
stopwatch and you tell yourself for
example I'm going to write for an hour
and a half today no matter what and I'm
going to monitor that on a stopwatch and
I will turn the stopwatch on when I'm
actually writing and when I'm not
writing like if the phone rings that I
have to take it or the house burned down
that I have to deal with that
then I will turn off the stopwatch until
that particular interruption is over
with and then I'll go back until I get
my hour and a half on the stopwatch and
it doesn't matter you know whether
you're doing it 3:00 p.m. or 3:00 a.m.
or 8:00 p.m.
etc as long as you get that hour and a
half on the stopwatch you are you know
you're in good shape so sometimes I have
three or four stop watches around
depending on what project I'm applying
them to and of course I've got my
computer stopwatch and I really look at
the time except if there's an
appointment or something that I have to
be aware of because I'm really focused
on you know my time which is the sava
watches time and that's what I need to
be focused on if I want to you know be
in that unique category of people who
create things and in my case manage
people create things
you